Hey, what's up guys
You probably know by now that i'm a huge fan of DeWalt tools
And i'm super stoked for this video, cause they just sent me a hole line-up of their next generation of power tools
Which aren't limited by cords or power outlets anymore
So, we jumped in the car and took a road trip to the Southern Utah desert, miles away from civilization
So we can put these things to the test and show you what they can do
Now on our way here we rented a truck and picked up a whole bundle of lumber
Because i'm really, truly curious to see how much lumber we can cut on one single charge
And out here in the desert, far away from civilization, there's no other source of electricity
But I don't want to cut these things on the ground
So let's get busy building ourselves a makeshift workbench first
So it's really as simple as taking some wood screws, fastening some 2x4's together, and building a sturdy surface
where we can start ripping wood, and do some run test to see how much mileage we can get on one charge
Could've been a Gymnast
And building this workbench was a really good chance for me to test out the DeWalt flexible battery
Because i swapped it from the Miter Saw to the Drill Driver, and to the circular saw, and it worked flawlessly and completely as advertised
Here's the basic idea of how it works
You've got your Drill Driver that works on 20 Volts
You pop the DeWalt flexible battery out and put it into your circular saw
This thing works on 60 Volts and the battery automatically switches voltages
So you're immediately good to go
But now you need to power your Miter saw, that runs on 120 Volts, just stick your battery in it
It doubles up to create 120 Volts, and there are no cords, so it's completely portable
So, it's actually pretty amazing technology
So, our work bench is finished, our tools are set
And I've got two DeWalt batterys that were freshly charged this morning
So, how much wood can we cut on one charge?
We're about to find out
(Musical Interlude)
Alright, quick update guys, our table saw has just stopped
which i'm assuming means that the battery has just died
Now, we've got ten 2x4's cut, nd each of them were 8 feet long
That means we've cut 80 linear feet of 1 1/2 inch thick 2x4
Let's throw on one more battery, do one more run, and see if the test results come out the same
Alright guys, just finished our second, that one was a little bit better, we got 12 and a half boards ripped
Remember, this is inch and a half
And i'm doing it by myself, for this next round, let's get Mark helping me out
We can just funnel these things through and see how many we can do as a team
Alright guys, so we've actually ripped three different rounds of three different charged batterys
And the results were pretty consistent
The first one, we ripped 10 boards on one charge
The second time, i got 12 and a half
And then with teamwork, we got 14 and 3/4
So, almost 15 boards
So I think the first round was a little bit lower due to the learning curve, it took me a little bit to catch onto this
But you can see they progressivly get better
These 2x4s are an inch and a half thick, so that's a lot of wood to rip through
And to be able to get between 12 and 14 consistently is pretty awesome
Let's move on to the Miter saw next, it takes two batteries
How many cuts can we make before those batteries die?
(Musical Interlude)
How long can this keep going?
Oh yeah, my arms are getting tired
And, there it goes, it finally died guys
Four hundred and fourty eight cuts
This litter Miter saw totally exceeded my expectations, and now we've got wood everywhere
So what are we gonna do with all this wood, there's only one thing I can think of, and thats to light it up
King of Random style
We're just about there, this is what we've been waiting for
Wow, that got hot fast
Wasn't quite the dramatic explosion I was going for, but it got the job done
That is an epic bonfire
Here we go
Whoa, the GoPro over-heated
Cool guys don't look at explosions
So there you have it guys, that's the new DeWalt flexible system
The power of corded, the freedom of cordless
And if you wanted to try these for yourself you can check them out at Flexible.DeWalt.com, i'll put a link down in the despription
So there you go, that's what happens when you give a guy cordless power tools and send him out in the desert
Hey, thanks for joining me for this video, i'll be looking for you in the next one
Talk to you then
Oh no, the quad copter